foreign
I had to leave my older children with
their dad in New York and you met
somebody new y'all had a a kid but this
guy lived in Chicago well my current
husband kept saying well it's not fair
that I get to be a part-time dad all of
this is predicated on your husband's job
[Music]
John deloney's show
show where we talked to real people
who find their lives upside down either
by their own doing or life has happened
to them or they have been stuck and
stuck stuck stuck they don't know what
to do next and so this is a real show
with real people we're talking mental
health talking relationships we're
talking marriage kids whatever you got
going on in your life my promises I will
tell the truth and I'll walk alongside
you and if I don't know the answer I'll
reach out to some of my expert
colleagues all over the country and do
my best or I might just say I don't know
and sometimes there's not a happy ending
to every one of these calls sometimes
reality is hard and it's scary and it's
gonna be long term or there's two or
three or four gnarly choices
but we're gonna do this together and so
if you want to be on this show give me a
buzz at
1-844-693-3291 it's
1-844-693-3291 or go to John deloney.com
ask ask
um and please please please please you
can change everybody's life
that's a little bit dramatic but please
just take a second to hit the Subscribe
button or the like button or the thumbs
up button or whatever buttons are on
whatever device you're
just buttons Hey listen Apple Google and
Spotify and everybody can we just
universalize how people say like I like
the show that would make my job easier
all right let's go to Jeanette in
chaitone in Chicago what's up jadette
hi Dr zaloni it's a pleasure finally
getting hold of you it's a pleasure to
talk to you what's up
uh Lots so I'm not sure where do I begin
um cannibal Cannonball right in the
middle
all right so I'm here in Chicago
actually it's an hour outside of Chicago
Illinois but um
just to for viewers and listeners
Chicago I guess it's a better uh Point
uh reference point
so I moved out here from originally from
New York about a year and a half ago I
have a blended family
and it's becoming
um extremely extremely painful for
myself my children my marriage the
entire move and I feel that it's been
perhaps a mistake
um not sure how to undo the damage or
how to move on
what brought you to the Chicago area
from New York
um about a about eight eight years ago I
met my current husband and he uh lives
here and so we've decided
um throughout different options that it
would be best for us to raise our
daughter together
and it was easier for me to get a
transfer from my job at the time
out here as opposed to him moving to New
York because he had a
job with pension and all sorts of
benefits that were not transferable hey
Jeanette you were being so so careful in
your language
laughs
can I can I be super honest with you
please you did something that you're not
proud of right
what is it yes what did you do
I can feel it how how professional and
um
carefully crap do you work for a large
company
yes yes you do I could tell by the way
y'all communicate with one another and
so just cannonball in what happened
um
older children
their dad in New York at that
how old
my oldest is 21 now
and the middle one is 17.
it was a year and a half ago and
nonetheless
very difficult
so let me let me back out so eight years
ago
you met somebody new y'all y'all had a
child together
you left your previous marriage
and you met somebody new y'all had a a
kid
yeah but this guy lived in Chicago so it
was a long distance thing
it was a long distance relationship for
a very long time up until a year and a
half ago what changed a year and a half
ago
[Music]
juggling work
um day cares and my older children were
Champs they actually helped in a lot
when I couldn't when the daycare was
closed due to covet they would always
help me out so I could go to work and
why'd you take the opportunity for them
to keep helping and being a part of
their family away from them
um
he well my current husband kept saying
well it's not fair that I get to be a
part-time dad and here's what's not fair
all of this is predicated on ah jeez man
all of this is predicated on the most
important thing in this relationship is
your husband's job
and for him to keep his fantasy little
world
he has to break up one unit that's
already been broken up once
because it's not fair
I don't what's not fair is he married
somebody and said choose me over your
children
that's not fair
because anybody who marries into marries
somebody who's already has kids via
another marriage has to know
those kids have to come first
I have to
your 17 year old's a child
she looks tough and she acts tough and
she's been through hell and back and she
grew up in New York so she probably
walks a little taller
she's a child
and that child needs your mama right
yes
even though we try to
FaceTime as much as we can that's not a
thing that's not a thing
I mean that's not a thing
I bring them out here as much as I can
as much as I
I possibly can with our crazy schedules
and
it's just not the same and he doesn't
seem to understand oh he understands he
doesn't care Jeanette
he doesn't care
because that was part of your old world
and he is your new world and so he
doesn't care
I think there's more to this
tell me I'm wrong and I'm perfect okay
being wrong
kids are one thing
but I think you've run into a stark
reality after six or seven years of
fantasy land which is like long distance
relationships it's so fun you can be
super you can be super intimate
electronically or on the phone it's very
different when homeboy won't pick up his
underwear or it's very different when
like why do we have to be so loud or so
quiet or whatever the thing is
I'm wondering if you moved to Chicago
and you in your marriage that you've
been in for a long time are wondering
what have I done
and the kids are just a part of that is
that fair
yes
that's very fair
so what do you do now
that's the good question I don't know
because
it seems that since I've been here our
marriage has been our relationship and
communication has gotten worse we hardly
ever talk
he just comes in
goes right to his phone
goes to bed
starts all over again next day we have a
different work schedules and
we hardly ever see each other now and
it's funny because when I lived in New
York and we had a long distance
relationship he made time to see
us we would face time we would talk we
would communicate a lot more
can we communicate now and I've tried
I've called him
said hey we should really set some time
aside to talk about our future
what we need to do and he always
gets either defensive or
loud and
the conversation has to end
So he responds like a child
I said
I said well I mean like I have a
seven-year-old and sometimes she'll come
in just and respond really loud
and it's disrespectful and we deal with
it but also she's seven it's pretty
normal
right it's not normal for a grown-up
with a job and a wife and a kid
right
I want you to be very very therapy do
what
we've also done therapy and
after a while he just
it just
dies out I want you to be very careful
about dragging your kids into this
because I don't think they're the issue
I don't want you looking at him and
saying I have to move back because of my
kids
because that's not wholly true
but you're gonna have to deal with the
shame of two marriages that didn't work
the a lost decade almost I mean you know
you know all those things right all
those feelings you will have whether
they're true or not true it's all going
to come it probably already all all is
crashed in on you
and him deciding to sue for custody and
all that mess and splitting time across
two cities and two states I mean all
that it's just it it is the reality
right right
the way you're describing it I don't see
a smooth transition he unless he just
lets y'all go
and which he might just do
he might want his little peaceful world
where he can just have an imaginary
girlfriend on the phone
and Via FaceTime but he gets to do
whatever he wants whenever he wants to
in his regular life maybe but he may
have been around how long how old your
daughter
um the youngest one is five she just
turned five okay
all right so I've been talking a lot how
can I help you
um that's the question how do I fix this
mess how do I go about fixing this how
do I do more talking to him do we do
more
marriage counseling
he doesn't seem to respond well on the
marriage counseling front he's been and
this should have been I guess the red
flag for me but
um he had previously been married twice
um but we always ignore those little
pesky red flags
I mean those are huge giant wavy Flags
right yeah
um they're not little pesky red ones um
I
it sounds like the thing you haven't
done through all of this is ask yourself
what does Jeanette want and what does
Jeanette need
and you've got to start with that
question
because you're going to counseling and
you don't really have a definitive
destination of where you're trying to to
head with this relationship
it's almost as it's almost like you're
stuck in a
in a free cycle in the fight fight or
freeze you're just gonna stuck
and I can imagine it's unnerving because
you're probably a gangster at work right
you're probably really good at your job
is that fair
I I would assume that just say yes just
say yes you do good at your job and then
it's so perplexing as to why this stuff
all doesn't work
and it's easy to just almost just sit
and drop your shoulders gonna put your
belly out and just kind of sit almost
like Buddha and just like I don't know
what to do and maybe we'll go to
counseling maybe we'll go to the gym
maybe we'll start reading up like
there's not really any goal
other than not this
and so it's kind of like getting in your
car and being like I just want to be
here I'm just going to drive
and then you both end up in different
places
and so I think you've got to ask where
do we want to go with this
what I want to do with my relationships
what I want to do with my kids what's
the best thing for this five-year-old
little girl what's the best thing for my
17 year old girl who's about to
transition into full-blown adulthood and
my influence over her will transition
from you have to from one of force to
one of influence
one of partnership and that's a tough
Transit you know you remember those days
that's a tough transition for any of us
oh yeah you got to ask yourself what are
those situations going to be like how do
we navigate that what do I want what I
need in that season
I mean that's where you gotta start
and then you have to be very very clear
with this dude
your husband
here's what I need here's what I want
and it sounds like if I'm being honest
um you've probably heard me say this
over and over on the show behavior is a
language sounds like he's being very
clear
Jeanette I don't care what you want I
don't care what you think I don't care
what you feel
this is what I'm gonna do and you can't
you can't be married like that
um I'm not uh I'm terrible at gambling
I'm awful at it like comically awful at
it
I'm wrong almost all the time
um but I'd be willing to bet that he's
talking to somebody else too
given the way you described how he
interacts with you and that he's got
more of a relationship with his phone
and he's got a multi-year history and it
would not surprise me if there's other
people that he's communicating with in
some shape form or fashion and I think
it's just sitting down and getting to
the bottom of that
and nobody wakes up and says man I
really want to be divorced twice it's
hard it's really really hard I've got
some of my close friends in the world
they've experienced this and it's just
tough it's it's it's shape-shifting
because I thought people who got
divorced twice were those people not me
and here we are
and you gotta own the reality that this
is where we are and then what are we
gonna do next
I think you gotta go sit with somebody
whether it's a close friend there in
Chicago whether it's a therapist
somebody in your local community and say
I need help sifting through the nonsense
what do I want and what do I need
and then I got to be real clear about
saying those things out loud very
directly
to my ex-husband to my kids to my
husband and to the Mirror
[Music]
and you get a stick to them
I think the run-in and the Haydn and the
I don't know and the ambiguity you got
to stop
you gotta stop because you're you're
bringing your kids under water too
call anytime Jeanette
so sorry what you're going through let's
make it right we'll be right back
[Music]
good folks slowing down is a critical
aspect of mental health calming music
prayers meditation they're all great
ways to find peace and hallow makes it
easy to start a daily practice of
meditation hallow is the number one
Prayer app in the world and you can
tailor content towards your faith
tradition from scripture readings and
prayers to journaling Hollow makes it
easy to practice prayer meditate and
build a deeper more meaningful spiritual
life and ReDiscover true peace go to
hollow.com deloney today to get three
months of hollow for free
hello.com deloney
all right we're back let's go to Dallas
Texas man homeboy called my bluff what's
up Nathan
how are you today Dr deloni I'm good all
right so to set the stage here the last
show
um
we reached out to your wife she wrote a
letter like an OG pen and paper letter
yeah
do what she said you love them
I love them
um but usually they're people send
letters like you know they're like real
happy or thank you so much or here's
here's how because of your show we've
I'm doing this now in my life and my
life's better
your wife's letter was like Hey I'm
dealing with this and I was like man we
gotta reach out to her well then halfway
through our conversation I'm like man I
really the person I need to be talking
to right now is your husband
and if he would call me that'd be
awesome and then here you are man oh
yeah kudos to you brother kudos to you
hey just so you know she talks really
good about you and you're not around
that doesn't happen a lot on the show
man so well done dude well way to be a
husband of Integrity who honors his wife
man that's cool all right so you in your
voice recap what's going on and how I
can help
bro a letter so
um I do know you know she was talking
about my mom and the whole situation
with her with her leaving and the way
she left
uh kind of put a strain on you know mine
and her relationship not my wives but my
mother's
and
oh man
is it almost exactly as I
thought it was going to play out so for
everybody
your mom
um met somebody on Twitter
right after 30 years of marriage or 30
plus years of marriage just surprises
everybody everybody thinks she went up
for a run and she moves away and then
she sends a message to your brother that
says I didn't just leave your dad I left
all of y'all this is over
right and then disappears yeah
that's exactly how it played out it's a
it's a lot to unpack really it was what
three four or five years ago
see it's right before me and my wife got
married
yeah this is also a week before your
wedding or two uh two months actually
good gosh man
so
I'm in Dangerous Ground both of us are
from Texas we both know we don't talk
about each other's moms Fair
yet I gotta talk about your mom is that
cool that's that's fine all right
I'll be as respectful as I can
um
what your mom did was one of what I
would consider a core evil
do you agree with that or no
yeah I agree
what part of you is still trying to hang
on and fix this relationship or make it
right
man uh you know it's one of those deals
the heart the heart says one thing and
heads as another
and it's real hard to
just don't cut ties because at the end
of the day that's still your mom but she
was so specific in how she cut ties with
you right
and you know it's one of those deals
it's like you want to come up with a
reason for why she did what she did
there's not one man maybe between her
and your dad but not you right right
and it's just one of those deals I guess
it's real hard to accept what she did
and you can't like I said you come up
with the reasons and it was well it was
better off for her to cut the ties to
make herself feel better
and you know it comes down to basically
selfishness it is is what it is yeah
and you you will never know ever the
dynamic behind closed doors of your mom
and your dad's relationship
that's like no one will ever know well
the way he looked at it or what he said
what he whispered good bad awful no one
will ever know
yeah and that's what's so hard about it
is you know you saw the outer Dynamic
you know what they put on on display 33
years of marriage and then uh my dad
worked the night shift and for him to
come home in the morning and she's just
gone uh she left her ring on the table
uh all the jewelry that us kids and
grandkids that bought her she left it
and just open Life didn't tell anybody
didn't say anything to anybody the only
person she told was a sister and that's
how we found out she left
and it's just that that the trail I
guess yeah
and I would tell you that the success of
your future mirrors the success of your
future parenting and the success of your
future emotional
health
is contingent on you making peace with
that betrayal not trying to fix it
right because you can't
it's so unimaginable it's not
unimaginable for a wife to get fed up
and leave her husband that happens all
the time and right sometimes good for I
mean way to go right
but to take all the kids jewelry
and to just try to control alt delete
a couple of sons and a daughter
that's evil yeah that's the embodiment
of it
has she tried to Circle back and say I'm
sorry and how's my kid like how is she
making her way because your wife's
question was I don't want this woman in
my house and but I also I want to love
my husband and I know he's in a weird
spot is she trying to make her way back
in or are you trying to
Create A New Path
honestly I feel like I'm trying to
create a new path because I don't know
if my wife had told you our son was born
two weeks ago oh congratulations oh dude
and you've got this picture that's not
gonna happen
right
and you know me growing up you know I
had my grandparents around but it wasn't
uh you know the uh Hallmark picture
perfect you know nothing ever is but you
know I had my grandparents around they
helped us out and you know the older I
get the more I look back and more my
memories are a word for them there
there's I feel like a lot of resentment
towards my grandparents and I don't want
that for my kid Nathan
there's you can't control that right
your mom cannot be around your kid
she can't
she's not a safe person of character who
I would put in the life of my child
for a number of reasons
but the hurt you felt and the pain you
felt
when two months before your marriage
your mom just evaporated in front of you
and sent a note saying
I'm leaving you too and here's all your
crap back that you've bought me over the
years
I'm not putting my my kid through that
or the chance that would happen now
if you know anything about me in this
show I'm always about Redemption always
if she comes back to you
on her knees saying I
committed a core core violation to the
soul of my children
and I'm so sorry
and y'all wanted to start a multi-year
process of regaining trust and regaining
connection and communication still
before you ever see my kids
I'd support that
support that
but you were you're creating you're
setting up a recipe for disaster in your
home because your wife is looking at you
at the woman who destroyed her husband
and after you've picked yourself off the
ground bloody scraped up completely torn
into
your wife hands you your first son
and you're heading back to that same
dragon that got you the last time
right
you've got to grieve the loss of that
picture brother because it's gone she
left
and dude I hate it for you man
I hate it for you
have you been anything other than angry
have you wept yet
um
honestly probably not I mean when she
first left you know us kids came
together real strong and then shortly
after we got married you know things
kind of fell apart
and that was probably the last time I
basically felt any emotion around my
family
face I usually just you know it's one of
those deals you just kind of try to
suppress it and work through it no you
don't you don't just impress it work
through it I I don't it's not depressing
but I I Channel it through my work you
know I'm a Hands-On guy so I just
you know I do my job and I work through
my process and you know I signed up for
better help you know you always talk
about that and I did better help good
and talked to my therapist and he helped
me through a lot of stuff good good
so
um
here's your homework assignment okay
and if you ever listen to this show
um
I I recommend this a lot but here's your
homework assignment it's going to be
unique to you
normally we do this when somebody's died
and in many ways
your mom did
right
the haunting part for you is
her ghost Still Remains and that just
It's haunting
because
if you are any human being at all
you're a son and you're asking yourself
what was so unlovable about me
what's so great about this Twitter Guy
what's so bad about my your grandson for
God's sake there will not be a rational
answer to for this because it's an
irrational Act
and so I want you to write and even if
you're not a writer you got to do this
I want you to write your mom a letter
one of them is going to be how angry you
are
and I want you for the first time to
actually feel this stuff
you did this to us
I was your son
the second thing letter I want you to
write to your mom
is a letter about heartbreak
I'm sad
and I want that to be the start of the
letter dear Mom I'm really sad
I had this picture of what my life was
gonna look like you were going to be a
part of it we were going to have a
different kind of relationship with
grandparents
you're going to be that crazy funnel
grandma that
whatever whatever
and you left me and I'm really sad
and the third letter you're going to
write your mom is dear Mom
so we're moving on
and I want you to let her know what
she's gonna miss
and here's some things she's going to
miss she's gonna miss how great of a
father her son's gonna be
and what a man of character and
integrity he's gonna be because he's
never gonna leave his kids or his wife
she's gonna miss t-ball games and she's
gonna miss when
your little one learns to walk and goes
and crashes into thing and the first ER
visit with the big gotta get stitches
and
gonna miss all that the recital and the
violin concert and the karate match or
whatever you can miss it all that stuff
and I want you to end that letter with I
wish you the best
and I hope your life has turned out how
you wanted it to and that's it and after
that we're setting this sucker down
and those will be three really tough
letters to write
yeah I mean they're already tough yeah
yeah but yeah she doesn't she she not
only does she not get to see your kid I
don't think you fully metabolized she
has told you I don't ever want to see
your kid
I don't ever want to see you
yeah you've got to take ownership of
that awful awful
gut-wrenching reality
it's the worst I I can't I'm sitting
here thinking
um
my son asked me this morning hey Jack
you dropped me off at work and he cleans
out the neighbors horse stalls and
spreads manure with this tractor thing
and he does a bunch of odd jobs for a
neighbor on their horse ranch
and I was like absolutely man I'm
leaving it this time this morning
um be ready to go he's like yes sir
and then I also walked into the shower
and
um no I went down to work out and then I
got up and went up in the shower and I
got to thinking about a talk I've got to
do this afternoon
and I heard banging on my door and I
thought the kids are just causing Havoc
like they do in the morning and I
totally ignored it
then I come out of my shower
like where is he
I was 20 minutes late
and he'd gone on sprinting down our
driveway that's about a quarter of a
mile
sprinting through the fields over the
creek
to get to work on time
and I was so ashamed I was sad that I'd
done that
and I drove my car over
to where he works and drove all the way
to the back pasture
and he saw me and he stopped the tractor
and he came over and I weighed him over
and I hugged him
and I said hey man I told you I was
going to be there to give you a ride
and I absolutely failed you I'm sorry I
lied to you I told you I wouldn't I
didn't I didn't show up wasn't a person
of integrity and he's like it's okay Dad
I said No Man's not okay
why do I tell you that
Nate I'm not the best dad in the world
man I'm trying to figure this thing out
but to send my son a letter that says
I'm leaving you too
I can't compute that
because I Dishonored my son this morning
by giving my word on something and not
coming through and I can't hardly
breathe
and so I want you to own the full
magnitude is what is of what has
happened to you because what's happened
to you is it is one of the core wrongs a
mom looking at her son and her and her
daughter saying
I'm leaving y'all
and you can't avoid it you can't just
suppress it you can't just work it like
get down feelings get down get down you
can man
because they will resurface and they
will wreak havoc on your new marriage on
your on your parenting with your kids on
your relationship with your siblings and
on and on and on
so the only path forward is through the
storm my brother
I'm I can't tell you how proud of you I
am for for calling better help and
getting some counseling that's awesome
want you to write these letters and in
some shape form or fashion commit to
your wife before I ever reach out to my
mom before I ever try to reconnect or at
some point she wants to reconnect
we will do this together because I'm
really emotional about it and I need
somebody who's going to give me some
perspective and insight that I may not
have when I get emotional and your wife
will say awesome
congrats on being a great husband and a
great dad my brother and for everybody
out there you have to choose reality go
to own reality here is what has happened
in my life The Good the Bad and the evil
it's only from that starting line can
you then ask what are we gonna do now
where do we go from here we'll be right
back
this show is sponsored by better help
folks take a minute to think about how
much time you spend on yourself it's
easy to get caught up in what people
need from you and want from you and
never think about what you need and then
you end up too stretched out burned out
all of the madness of our current world
resting on your shoulders
look sometimes I put my head down to
work and then realize I haven't had a
meaningful conversation with my wife and
kids all day I get focused on what I'm
doing and I'm running and running and
running
and I don't know how to come back
therapy is a great way to learn new
skills that make you the best version of
yourself to help you set boundaries and
still have energy left to help others
without leaving yourself behind so if
you're thinking of starting therapy give
better help a try it's totally online to
fit into your schedule you just fill out
a brief questionnaire to get matched
with a licensed therapist and you can
switch therapists at any time for no
additional charge so find more balance
find Wellness with better help visit
betterhelp.com deloney today to get 10
off your first month that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash deloni
all right we're back let's go to
Savannah Georgia and talk to the great
Maggie what's up Maggie
nervous Doctor John hey do me a favor
yes I can't believe hey do me a favor
Maggie can you talk directly into your
phone
yes it is a huge phone is that better
that is so good much better yes okay I
am so nervous I'm sorry if I start
shaking a little bit how are you guys
dude I promise I'm more nervous than you
because I'm not great at this so you are
good you're in good hands and if I screw
something up which probably will Kelly
and Jenna can rescue the day so it's all
good
all right so I talked to you Miss Jenna
and she told me just to lead with the
original question and then kind of go
into background so uh my original
question I guess the core question is
um am I doing the right thing by moving
out of my home while my husband is in
rehab and detox for the second time
um and then kind of a follow-up leading
on questions then is how do I Rectify
that
yes I'm terrified and that's
understandable but um it just doesn't
feel right and I can't Rectify that yes
it's the logical thing to do and likely
the safe thing to do but it feels like
I'm completely abandoning
um my husband in that situation so um
this background me and my husband were
both active duty in the military I'm not
going to go into the specific branch and
what we do but it's they're both pretty
demanding jobs uh Dr John and um
so this has been going on
for a couple of years and this is his
second time in rehab which is why I do
want to protect him in his career and
his identity because he has done a lot
for this country and um
but the first time he went uh he wasn't
completely voluntary
um but he did uh it was a mental savior
kind of thing he was in a really bad
place and unfortunately he started
talking about
um ending his life and we got him there
and we got him help and he's safe now
but uh he hasn't been struggling with
drinking for a long time and um his
and escalated to a point again to where
he was mixing medication and alcohol and
um there has been Sports of violence not
at me directly just
around me and the final mail in the
coffin I guess was I found
very inappropriate and um Unfaithful
messages between him and his ex-wife and
um I I just feel like there's a light
switch that went off and um
yeah I guess I'm just looking for if I'm
doing the right thing am I being soil or
giving up too early
um I'm just I just feel stuck I don't
know if that makes any sense sir oh it
makes all the sense in the world you
articulated that very well
um
yeah if we were in the same room
together I would stop the conversation
and just ask if I give you a hug for a
second
because I think you probably gave me the
most sanitized version of that story you
possibly could because you're a person
of honor and integrity right
oh yes sir yeah
I'm gonna give you two hard hard truths
okay
that sometimes run a little bit counter
to
some of your own training
okay
um
hard truth number one
you can't save him
and you have to fully metabolize that
reality
you can call when you need to call and
I'm so proud of you for calling
and you can help with the intake
paperwork and you can be a part of the
treatment process we'll talk a little
bit about that in a second
but you can't save him
and you love this guy and this guy
you've you've seen sides of this guy
that should be put in bronze and put out
in front of buildings across this
country and you've also seen sides of
the sky that are terrifying
Fair
you can't save him
the second thing is
you must stay safe
and if you are active duty and you have
any sort of combat training when it goes
down
you train for years
to shut off that switch it says go run
and hide and to reprogram yourself with
if I got somebody in the line I'm going
down too
and it doesn't work here
because what happens is you both end up
dead
metaphor metaphorically speaking you
gotta stay safe
he again I've and I guess that's the
scary part is I've never felt physically
and harms I'm not talking I'm not
talking about physical safety that's
part of it
and I
I bet it's escalating on you
and
um and you're smart enough to see it
coming is what I'm saying but there's
also emotional safety there's relational
safety there's psychological safety
there is well do I have an STD now
there is am I just a sucker is this what
I'm worth kind of safety that start
those old childhood conversations up
like you know the voice that's been
talking to you since you were a little
girl that voice comes back loud and
clear you know I mean all that stuff
that's all wrapped up in safety
and anyone who tries to parse safety
apart is usually a big six foot two 200
pound guy
because safety is a lot more than that
than just did he swing at you or not
the fair
yes sir
so no I think you're doing the right
thing
if your body's telling you we got to get
out of here I want you to honor
the most important radar system you have
overreacting
to that situation and specifically you
know I I feel like he cheated on me okay
the messages and conversation that
aside from the physicality and honestly
not having a husband because he
has been so intoxicated or on some kind
of medication
um for so long
um I just could not go
down that that hole
with him as much as I wanted to I just I
I can't pull him out of that and you're
absolutely correct but somebody's got to
stay outside the well and at some point
Pull the Rope up
if you're both good on the well you're
both you both drown
yeah
yeah sir and just
that that is
cheating as well I know I keep harping
on that one thing but you know
you don't have to apologize you don't
have to you don't have to you don't have
to confirm the story
you're allowed to feel whatever it is in
the world you want to feel
and I think your heart knows it's
probably more than just text messages
because usually when somebody finds text
like that they look backwards in a whole
bunch of puzzle pieces fall into line
and it's just this oh my gosh and you've
probably heard me say this on the show I
think the most devastating thing about
those kind of messages finding out the
person you love and let's be honest
[Music]
I usually say this metaphorically you've
been to war
but you've been in the trenches with
this guy through two rehab students
you've given up career you've given up
sleep you've given up sanity you you may
have given up starting a family you get
up a bunch of stuff for this and so to
find this is
it's it's to call it maddening is
undermining it but I think the worst
part of this the betrayals hardcore
the disgust and that feeling I want to
throw up and I can't believe who are you
that stuff's that stuff's devastating
but I think the more devastating thing
is now Maggie doesn't trust Maggie
anymore
because either Maggie knew this was kind
of happening ish maybe sort of and
didn't do anything and Maggie's kind of
a gangster in every other part of her
life or Maggie missed it all
and Maggie's gotta look in the mirror
and go if we miss this what else have we
missed it's it's unmooring right it's
like it's like the foundation of your
house just evaporates
yes
I don't know what I don't even know it's
real anymore there you go
that's safety
okay and you've heard me say this a
million times and it applies here too I
want you to choose guilt over resentment
um do you have dreams of this marriage
circling back up
um
I have told
other place
lined up but I did tell him I wasn't
filing for a divorce that I'm absolutely
willing to go to counseling
but um I I do require uh sobriety and
you know just a chance for us
hopefully
I'm not saying it's not possible but I
just don't know how to even begin to
rebuild that trust like I feel like that
was such a foundational
um thing for a marriage to work that if
he did not hold our marriage in the same
level and view it as something that
needs to be cherished and protected
and he stepped outside of that no matter
how he was feeling isolated because I
truthfully felt just as isolated and
alone this whole time but I I never
would have turned against him I was
doing everything I can to support him
through this and then in the hopes that
we could find each other again and work
through this and um
so no I haven't filed for divorce or a
legal separation yet I am willing to go
to counseling and work on it if
he does the work as well okay I
I think that sounds beautiful
I always tell everybody to not make
decisions in the fog like this
but I do think you're very wise and if
he was my best friend in the world
or if he was on the phone with me right
now I'd be heartbroken for him he no
chance he wants to be where he is
and I would say hey man she needs to
move out for a while
it's the right thing
there's got to be some some clearance
here
so the smoke and clear we can figure out
what's up and what's down
and so I I would tell anybody that
when it comes you if you're in love with
somebody who struggles with addiction
gotta choose safety you got to make sure
you're okay and you're safe
and your whole my friends or I'm not
abandoning somebody that
I've committed to I know that sounds
like a doormat but no it doesn't because
that's I mean that's who you are
that's who you are
you going to hell to get your friends
out that's who you are
that's why I I want you to hear me say
you can't get him out of this one
it's a suicide mission you can't get him
out
you can be sitting right there at the
edge of the light with your arm extended
as far as your fingers will reach when
he chooses to exit
and sometimes you may find a counseling
there's all sorts of none of this none
of this is going to be any sort of
excuse at all zero
but weird things happen in the hearts
and minds of people who struggle with
addiction and it wouldn't surprise me if
he was trying to figure out a way to get
some space between the two of you
because he didn't want to hurt you
anymore he loves you that much
and you're thinking well this was about
the stupidest way you could I know
right
so who knows what happens down the road
but I think you learning to trust Maggie
again is really important
and choose guilt you're going to feel
guilty you're going to feel and I don't
know what kind of guy he is he may be
saying like yeah I know you've got I
know I know I know I screwed up and or
he may just be laying it on thick I
don't know
um but you're gonna feel guilty that's
just who you are
you don't leave somebody and you feel
like you're leaving
I'd rather you do that
and give this relationship a Fighting
Chance than to just continue to simmer
until suddenly you are in Coal of Ash
and you resent the very name of this guy
because I think he comes back and then
he comes back and you'll have some
decisions to make
you gotta make those decisions in
moments of clarity
I hate this for you sister I hate it I
hate it I hate it I hate this for him
I want wholeness and wellness for both
of you
but I'll say this like from the bottom
of my heart I'm proud of you for looking
at Maggie in the mirror and saying
Maggie we are worth keeping safe here
we're with trusting our gut
and we got to step out for a minute
sounds wise to me
good for you we'll be right back
[Music]
hey deloney here one of the things I
love about my job is answering the tough
questions people have when they call
into the show your stories are
incredible in each person's situation is
unique and for years people from all
over the world have been asking if I do
private counseling or private coaching
sessions for them or for their spouse
and as much as I'd love to I can't
realistically do one-on-one coaching
sessions with every single person it's
just not possible but that's exactly why
I wrote my new book own your past change
your future within the pages of this
book is exactly what I would say if you
and I were sitting down together at a
table looking for the next right move
for you to make in your relationships or
to help you live a more whole and
peaceful life as you read through each
section of this book I will show you how
to look and own the roads from your past
and head to the New Roads of a well life
moving forward go to John deloney.com to
get your copy today that's own your past
change your future at John deloney.com
all right as we wrap up today's show
songs in 1996 or it's a throwback many
of you weren't even born yet
it's a song by Lisa broke up
not bro cop but bro cop
songs called she can't save him goes
like this she can hear his car as it
pulls in the drive she can whisper a
prayer thank God he's alive she can meet
him at the door catch him when he falls
but she can't save him she can make his
coffee in the cold light of day she can
make his excuses tell the boss he'll be
late she can wave at the neighbors and
kiss him goodbye
but she can't save him
sometimes she dreams that he's caught in
a stream and the water keeps pulling him
down she reaches for him as he pulls her
in she wakes up just before she drowns
nothing can change until he saves
himself
she can't save him
[Music]
it's a good word love you guys see you
soon